y algo ha dejado claro el conflicto en
ucrania es que nadie es más creativo y
eficaz anexionándose o liberando
territorios al margen del derecho
internacional que rusia su presidente
vladimir putin está convencido de la
grandeza de su nación y ha dejado caer
en varias ocasiones que la desmembración
de la unión soviética fue a su manera de
ver la mayor catástrofe geopolítica del
siglo 20 así no es de extrañar que desde
el kremlin se las están ideando para
recuperar el poderío geopolítico que
consideran que les corresponde
históricamente rusia considera que los
países de la antigua unión soviética
deben permanecer bajo su influencia y en
consecuencia otros países no deberían
incurrir en sus asuntos ya que sería
meter las narices en los asuntos de
rusia el problema es que intentan dictar
los estándares y soluciones en contra de
nuestros intereses efectivamente nos
están diciendo que son mejores que
nosotros que saben mejor lo que
necesitamos por favor dejen que
decidamos nosotros sobre nuestros
intereses sin necesidad de solucionar el
mismo thriller pero ya no contentas con
la existencia de unas antiguas
repúblicas soviéticas demasiado
independientes para su gusto rusia lleva
unos años apoyando a las regiones más
pro rusas de todos estos países en sus
procesos de independencia ya os hablamos
de cómo está gestionando rusia la crisis
en el este de ucrania
siendo unilateralmente y de facto la
independencia de ernest y lugar sin
considerar las de momento parte de su
territorio
ciudades del donbass como por ejemplo 10
como de valls evo la propia nick y si no
de la que hablamos a su momento ha sido
literalmente arrasadas por la guerra más
de un millón de personas estima que han
tenido que escapar a otras partes del
país incluso las universidades se han
visto forzadas a cerrar sus cuerpos pero
no es la primera vez que lo hacen antes
vinieron crimea afasia osetia del sur y
la más desconocida pero que está
volviendo a ganar importancia al nuevo
contexto de movida y tira y afloja con
la otan transnistria que es el tema de
hoy
transnistria es uno de los lugares más
extraños que existen pasear por las
calles de tiráspol su capital supone
retroceder 40 años en el tiempo regresar
a la época de la unión soviética o
sentirse en una especie de corea del
norte occidental transnistria está
situada en europa del este dentro del
territorio que anteriormente formaba la
república socialista soviética de
moldavia que era parte de la unión
soviética pues bien la situación hoy de
este territorio en la comunidad
internacional es bastante peculiar
transnistria es un estado no reconocido
es decir un país en la práctica
independiente pero que formalmente
continúa perteneciendo a moldavia
[Música]
la división de moldavia
de la misma manera que el dniéper divide
a ucrania en dos regiones separadas
ideológicamente el míster divide desde
1990 a moldavia entre literalmente el
estado de moldavia y la republica de
transmisión las diferencias entre los
habitantes de ambas regiones son
principalmente étnicas y lingüísticas
mientras que moldavia está formada por
moldavos humano parlantes trans cristian
está formada por una mayoría eslava que
habla como lengua principal el ruso o el
ucraniano fue de hecho el miedo a la
romanización del país tras su
independencia lo que sumió a los ruso
fonos del este en una crisis de
identidad ya que tras la caída de la
unión soviética perdieron el dominio
cultural que hasta entonces tenían en el
país
[Música]
en este contexto y automáticamente tras
la restauración de la independencia de
moldavia en 1990 transnistria quiso
unirse a la ola de democratización que
en aquel entonces liberaba a las 14
repúblicas soviéticas algo que no se vio
con buenos ojos desde chisinau
[Música]
y las tensiones entre la capital moldava
y tiráspol fueron escalando hasta causar
una auténtica guerra civil que duró
desde marzo hasta julio del 92 pero no
solamente hubo moldavos y tránsitos
enfrentados en este conflicto en efecto
rusia se posicionado de parte de
transnistria y se pasó por ahí para
asegurarse de garantizar su
independencia
[Música]
la que ya terminó con un alto al fuego
que se lleva respetando desde entonces
pero este alto el fuego no solamente
ponía fin a las hostilidades sino que
oficializaba la entrada de tropas rusas
al este del cni esther que más de 20
años después siguen ahí con el pretexto
de apoyar al gobierno transmitió a día
de hoy en transnistria están desplegados
2500 soldados rusos así como más de
20.000 toneladas de armas y municiones
propiedad de rusia según un veredicto
emitido por el tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos la presencia de estas
tropas es ilegal y supone que este
territorio está bajo la autoridad
efectiva o por lo menos bajo la
influencia decisiva de rusia
obviamente para los moldavos esto en su
día supuso un acto hostil que violaba su
integridad territorial y la verdad es
que el derecho internacional les ampara
porque desde chisinau no se ha
autorizado la intervención pero ellos
tampoco tienen el poder para echar a
rusia ya que el alto al fuego les impide
hacer nada que comprometa la
independencia de transnistria
[Música]
esta particular identidad de
transnistria aunque sólo haya sido
reconocido hasta ahora por otras tres
regiones como están independientes
osetia del sur asia y nagorno karabaj lo
cierto es que transmite actualmente
funciona con un verdadero estado
independiente tiene su propia moneda el
rubro de transmisión tiene su propio
himno nacional su propio pasaporte al
que sus ciudadanos tienen derecho sin
rechazar al moldavo e incluso un banco
republicano transmitió independiente del
moll dado que a pesar de que no les han
reconocido realmente como estado
independiente el amor de la región por
rusia es más que obvio de hecho este
mismo mes se ha llevado ante la corte
suprema- transnistria una iniciativa por
la que la bandera rusa tendría el mismo
estatus que la bandera nacional esto es
que la bandera blanca azul y roja se
podría en todos los edificios públicos y
sería a ojos de los transmitió su propia
bandera
[Música]
la predilección de los trans ministros
con rusia llega a tal punto que en 2013
el consejo supremo de transnistria
aprobó el uso de la legislación rusa en
todo el territorio de esta
autoproclamada república actualmente se
están eliminando todas las disposiciones
legales que sean contradictorias con la
legislación rusa el objetivo último de
las autoridades de este territorio es
claro incorporar la república a la
federación rusa sin embargo para poder
lograrlo moscú tiene que reconocer
primero su independencia
viendo este amor tan incondicional
porque no reconoce rusia transnistria
como estado independiente la respuesta
es que al kremlin le interesa que en
cierta manera transmisión siga
perteneciendo a moldavia para poder
usarla como baja en su estrategia
geopolítica así moscú puede evitar
fácilmente que moldavia tome cualquier
decisión que le aleje de su radio de
influencia se os ocurre que quiere
evitar el kremlin principalmente en
efecto rusia se encarga de esta manera
de que moldavia no tenga la feliz idea
de subirse al carro de la otan o de
acercarse más de la cuenta a la unión
europea cosa que ya hicieron sus vecinos
rumanía y ucrania con las consecuencias
para la segunda que ya todos conocemos
[Música]
aunque de momento no parece que haya
ninguna intención por parte de moldavia
de unirse a ninguna organización
internacional occidental especialmente
desde los resultados de sus elecciones
en octubre en las que salió victorioso
el pro ruso igor dodon que ha prometido
alejarse de europa y reforzar los lazos
de chisinau con moscú
el socialista pro ruso igor dodon se
convirtió en el nuevo presidente de
moldavia tras obtener en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2016 casi el 52% de
los votos donde es un ferviente
admirador del presidente ruso vladimir
putin su intención como presidente pasa
por frenar la integración con la unión
europea y firmar un acuerdo de
asociación estratégica con rusia
un nuevo kaliningrado pero no nos
olvidemos de que a todo esto sigue
habiendo tropas rusas en un territorio
extranjero algo que en bruselas no
sienta del todo bien porque recordemos
que además de permitirle controlar a
moldavia la situación política y
geográfica de transnistria también le da
la posibilidad a rusia de controlar
militarmente un territorio que ahora
mismo resulta clave
en primer lugar hacia el este de
transnistria tiene la frontera con
ucrania
ahora mismo sumida en una guerra contra
rusia por las regiones del donbass por
lo que seguirá a orillas del dniéper les
da la posibilidad de cercar a ucrania
desde dos flancos distintos ejerciendo
una presión que baila entre la
diplomacia dura e irlanda para
recordarles que el oso ruso está ahí
velando por su territorio
y por otra parte hacia el oeste la
manutención de tropas en el cni esther
puede verse como una respuesta al
refuerzo militar que está realizando la
otan en rumanía algo que moscú se ha
visto como un acción agresiva por parte
de la organización la otan inauguró hoy
en el sur de rumania un controvertido
escudo antimisiles diseñado y financiado
por eeuu esto es correcto
este es un sistema que está dirigido
contra amenazas procedentes de fuera de
la zona euroatlántica rusia sabe eso
hemos sido muy transparentes sobre los
planes y las intenciones de este sistema
así que no hay razón para que se
incremente la atención de gestión no son
sistemas defensivos son parte del
potencial nuclear estratégico de eeuu
emplazado en la periferia después del
emplazamiento de estos elementos del
escudo antimisiles nos veremos obligados
a pensar en cómo neutralizar las
amenazas a la seguridad de rusia en
definitiva rusia en contra transmite a
su segundo kaliningrado que en estos
momentos le resulta más útil que nunca y
vosotros creéis que en algún momento
veremos una transmisión independiente o
que por el contrario en moldavia
conseguirá recuperar algún tipo de
control sobre la región
el tema del vídeo dadle a like y
suscribiros al canal y nos vemos en la
próxima
y por supuesto no te olvides dejar tu
opinión en los comentarios
[Música]